I also saw the disturbing articles on Rekola site about the MRDA in our food supply.
Is there anything we could do to detox it? So it doesn't accumulate and hurt us as bad.
Well, there's no perfect way to detox the MRDA because there's just not enough note about it.
Now, I've always said that the lumbarol kinase and nato kinase is, oh, why did I change that?
Is some of the best things to help detox the MRDA, plus your binders? So nato kinase and lumbarol
kinase are enzymes. We actually have a brand new product that we actually have two brand new
private label products. What is called circulation of clear, clear circulation.
And the other one is clear tox. So clear tox was actually created specifically
to detox the MRDA vaccine. It has lumbarol kinase, so does the circulation clear,
has lumbarol kinase and nato kinase. But if you have issues from the vaccine or from being exposed
to people with the vaccine and having heart issues, I would take the circulation clear.
If you're like, no, I don't have any of those issues, I just don't want to have issues. I'm trying to
detox this MRDA vaccine, then take the clear tox.
Clear tox has some other binders and things in it that circulation clear has,
the more things that it support your heart. The clear tox has more things in it. It has both the
lumbarol kinase and nato kinase, both of them do, but it also has stuff in there to help detox the
tox. So